[Musique]
on ne se connaît pas mais je voulais
vous dire merci
si vous saviez combien vous avez changé
ma vie sans vraiment savoir vous avez
fait de la magie moi qui ne croyaient
plus en moi ni en l'avenir
combien de vols est devenu tout
en l'air
je n'avais plus de force et l'envi
données firmes à quai
n'avait plus de souffle pour faire
tourner la roue jusqu'au jour où le
destin vos amis sur ma route
oui c'est vous
kim a affirmé m
grrrr ma flamme s'est rallumée et
on a toujours eu ce moment de magie 3 0
histoire
pour les arts de la rue
oui
[Musique]
et
on ne se connaît pas mais vous m'avez
thème a pris vos mots vos sourires et
vos larmes ont sauvé la vie faux combat
remonte appris à encaisser les coups et
votre persévérance à me remettre debout
aux médailles en redonner vie à mes
rêves de gamin aux valeurs on appris ce
qu'est vraiment être nulle
un second souffle qui m'a fait je
remercie le destin de vous avons mis sur
ma route
oui c'est vous
que pas vers elle et m
[Musique]
grâce à vous
c'est à lui même
on
ag
[Musique]
2 0